in Flores. Brian Flores, has a
history with New England.
Miami. They've won five straight
Washington. They've
won four straight. How are they
putting these streaks together
there in Washington and in
Miami?
Just, you know, a both teams,
both both teams or both
coaches, the players believe in
these guys, you know, they just
believe in how hard Ron Rivera
think about Ron Rivera when
going through cancer
on the players saw
all the sacrifices, so they love
and they respect their
coach. You think about Brian
Flores if they didn't love and
respect their coach at one in
78? Would have quit, they will
quit, but they've won what, five
or six in a row. They've
been outstanding. They have a
lot of respect for Brian
Flores and one thing.
Out him knowing him for my
Patriot days. He's going to
continue to fight and Claw to
get this team back on top. So,
you know, I got a lot of respect
for both the Washington
football team and the Dolphins,
you know, Ron Rivera and Brian
floor is getting his
players to play for him.
It's fun to watch to a place.
Some of his best football to
right now because this is
starting to look like to or
from Alabama. He started to look
comfortable and confident
back there and early in his
career. He kind of had Happy
Feet. If you
know what I mean, he'd be he'd
have someone open but he's sort
of shuffling his feet and now
he's throwing it and throws all
over the place. Like watch, Tom
Brady play Lookout settled. His
feet are, look how tall he
stands in that pocket. I'm
starting to see to a play like
that. Now in the throws are
starting to hit. And yeah, he's
athletic and he can,
he can layer all of that on top
of it, but he's finally
starting to Settle his feet.
When you ever serious like
waddle. They have great tight
end play right there. My kiseki
is somebody really leads that
charge for them. So if he can
just get these guys the ball
Parker's another playmaker on
the outside.
This offense has a little
Firepower
and like you're saying Brian
Flores knows exactly what he's
doing defensively.
Absolutely in the impact of
rookie wide receiver. Jalen W.
Oh, he's giving his offense some
explosiveness that they
haven't had. He's got the
familiarity with tour and like
you said to us starting to look
like an NFL quarterback. You
told me that on Sunday. I said,
let
me live pay a little bit more
attention and you're absolutely
right. He's starting to look
like he's playing with
confidence. He's, you know, he's
just doing all the little
things that it takes
to be a really good quarterback
in this league and we see with
the defense and with the weapons
that they have on Let's
just continue to incorporate
that run game
to try to keep it a little bit
more balanced and it should be
okay.
Speaking of that run game. I was
having fun going back and
wash it watching the Washington
football team. I just wanted to
go back and watch that game and
Taylor heinicke was taken some
massive shots. He was getting
beat up back there.
But what's fun to watch about
him is he pops right back up?
And he plays just a true
competitor. He's just a pure
competitor. They have an awesome
Run game. That
offensive line is one of the
most underrated in the NFL to
me,
Leno, Junior, flowers, Sheriff,
Lucas, They're all playing
dominant football. So, four of
their five are extremely Ali
graded on the offensive line and
so when you watch him play
behind it, when you watched
Antonio Gibson, get going as
a young running back behind
them.
All of a sudden the Washington
football team. Even without
Chase, young is right back in
the thick of this playoff
picture. How do you think they
got here?
When I got here through their
head coach to hits their head?
Coach Ron, Rivera and doesn't
play. He holds these guys
accountable and he'll let you
know one thing about Ron. I say
he keeps it real. He's going to
let you know what his
expectations are
just like when he came out and
said I have no, Interest in Cam
Newton, Ron Rivera is going to
hold his players accountable.
They respect them. He treats
them like men and he is
a certain expectation level.
And if you need it, you're going
to be there. If you don't
meet it, you're going to be out
the door. That's why I love
them.
That's right. And then you got a
guy like heinicke who throws.
There's a bad interception. It
was in the fourth quarter,
the prior series. He throws a
bad interception. They get the
ball
back there down one, there's two
minutes and 22 seconds left
and heinicke. Still believes. He
makes about five great
throws to get them
back. Down the field into field
goal range. They hit
the game-winner. See there's
just starting to be a belief and
I'm
with you. That seems to come
from their head coach get to
your second takeaway right here
rod and your second takeaway is
what Arizona the
Cardinals. They are back to full
force. What did you
With Kyler returning.
He gave them, he definitely gave
them a spark. I mean,
I think with his speed and the
decision-making, you could tell
that this is completely
different offense. They, it's
just so much more dangerous when
you have calamari running
around and you see what the
little
reception of d-hop. In The End
Zone,
they still have that connection.
But this is a guy
that really has impressed me.
James Conner, you know, and
last year we thought he was done
with the Pittsburgh
Steelers. All this guy can't
play anymore.
But now you give him some decent
blocking.
You give them a quarterback that
can scramble you, give
them a passing game. Now, James
Conner is a different guy. And
once we talked about Colin
Murray, not trying to do too
much. Just taking a simple
things allowing his defense to
fly around and make plays
for interceptions three sacks, a
bunch of pass breakups. We
know Buddha, Baker and Chandler
Jones and them guys. They've
been great this year.
I'm with you. I think what they
did with Kyler was really smart
to sit him with the lower leg
injury, especially while
they're winning because they
were winning a couple of games
right Colt McCoy's in there, but
they're still finding ways
to win.
If they're going to really do
something substantial this year.
It's going to be what the
healthy Kyler Murray so they
really took their time, getting
him back, getting them all
the way. Healthy. That's what he
looked like. I mean, how many
quarterbacks in the NFL, do you
see that scared defensive backs
with their speed? And you can
forget about the fence events.
He gets around them with no
problem,
but defense Beck's. Don't know
what to do with them when he
gets into the second level. And
that's some scary scary speed
to me. They are one of the big
three when I look at the NFC
Green Bay, Tampa,
and the Cardinals. Those are my
big three in the NFC. What's
your take on those three all in
one group?
I agree with you balls. I agree
with you Arizona, Green Bay and
Tampa Bay, you talking about
arguably, you know, with Tampa
band and
the Green Bay, Packers two of
the best quarterbacks in
the league. You got Colin
Murray. They're the most
dangerous
quarterback in the league, I
think. You're spot-on. I like
those Pig but don't sleep on
Tampa Bay. I'm telling you
as the defense gets a little
healthier.
They're going to come back and
went and at the end of the day.
They're going to be right there.
That's right. Let's get to your
third takeaway. This one comes
from Sunday Night Football, Rod.
The Broncos. They got all
those Playmakers. You were
talking about on the entire
pregame show, you really like
two receivers, you like Javonte
Williams out
of the backfield, but I'm going
to focus you in on
the quarterback and Teddy
Bridgewater. What do you think
of the most important player?
Look man, I love Teddy
Bridgewater. We know that he's
a good kid. He's been hurt, we
cheered for them, you know and
all those different things but
at the end of the day
the Broncos need
another quarterback, they got to
get them a quarterback.
Teddy Bridgewater is an average
Quarterback. He's not going to
make a ton of mistakes, but he's
not going to do a bunch of
great things. You look at the
weapons, like you talked about
Jerry Judy in the
slot. You got two receivers that
are 63 64 bit guys. You
got no offense and you're
throwing a directly to Juan
Thornhill and the defense. I
just don't get it. They're
going to have to find someone
and makes an impact. There's
nothing about Teddy. Bridgewater
outside of his
rehab and everything that he's
done.
You know, when he was injured,
that inspires me when I'm on
a field. I don't see that. I
don't see that fire. I don't
see anything like that. I like
Teddy Bridgewater as a person,
but at the end of the day, if
the Broncos want to win and
utilize all the money that
they've invested in those wide
receivers. You got Jared Judy.
You drafted in the first round,
you got Javonte Williams
as the running back. You drafted
him in the second round.
You Going to have to get a
quarterback that can play this
game at a high level in Teddy,
Bridgewater camp.
That's right. Andrew Luck. Can't
either. So like when you
look at this team, they're
playing good defense. You got
Javonte Williams who was just
carrying defense has running
the football. We were talking to
Tyrann Mathieu after
the game.
How about the way he was talking
about Javonte Williams.
He's basically like you're
trying to get down there and
position to find a, but by the
time he Ducks underneath those
offensive linemen. He's already
so low, you can't even get
leverage on him. He had so much
respect for Williams as
a rookie, which was awesome to
hear Jerry Judy's, finally
healthy. You were just talking
about just On both of their
other receivers and Sutton and
Patrick to contract extension.
So they believe in everybody
else.
The defense has even been
playing pretty well without Von
Miller, but they just can't find
consistency at
the quarterback position and
it's really starting to hurt
this
team. Let's get you to your
fourth one,
a quarterback who has been very
consistent. Tom Brady starting
to look really dangerous and his
man Gronk. How about
the way he's flying around?
Grunt looks like he's been on TV
12. He looks like he's 28
years old. Like
when I watch grunk plague,
it's like he's running smooth.
He's not tight. He's catching
passes. Not only is he catching
passes? He's catching passes
against linebackers safeties and
cornerbacks. He's getting
off the line. He's been
healthy and Tom sticks with him.
I don't care if you get up
there. You jam. Rob Gronkowski a
little bit. He's going to
continue to fight and Claw. You
got a double team as guy
especially when they get in a
row.
Do one guy cannot stop him. He's
67 270 pounds and I don't
understand what the hell
defensive coordinators are
doing.
How can this safety right here,
Eric? I forget his last name,
but he used to play for
the Raiders. You can't guard,
Rob Gronkowski with this kid.
You
can't. It's unfair. It's not
even right to ask him to do
something like that. Rob is one
of the greatest tight ends to
ever play
in the history of football. If I
were defensive coordinator,
he will good. He would get
double team every single play.
He's in a Red Zone. He wouldn't
catch. Chapped ass.
That's right. That's right. This
look like old times to me.
I mean, it's crazy to watch.
Grand could be one thing. If
you is sort, you know, League
decade-plus. It'd be one thing
if he was out there
looking like an old man and kind
of just having his last
go-around in the league with
Brady, or what have you. But
I'm right there with you, on the
tee, B12 stuff. I mean,
I haven't seen Gronk stride out
like this since about 2015
or something. It's like, I'm I
cannot believe the way he's
running, if they can figure out
a way and maybe arrest him.
Maybe you just
My game, oh, baby, you're
playing one. We give them
a week off, play him again, be
very strategic about when you
use them. But if you can get him
through this full 18 weeks
season, if you can get him to
the playoffs,
I don't see any reason why we,
I'm starting to really believe.
We may be looking at a Tampa
and a New England, Super Bowl
Brady Belichick rematch. Can you
imagine if we got that one
on, NBC my goodness,
deriving Harrison. Tell you that
on Sunday down. I'm not
sure. I think you might have
told me that. Like two months
ago Rod to be perfect. Ha ha ha
forget about Sunday. But I'ma
tell you this,
for real, what I think too,
what's happened with Tampa's
passing game is Leonard
fournette.
He's actually making a
difference. I mean, he's
catching a lot of passes out of
the backfield, which is really
opened up opportunities for Rob,
Gronkowski. Because as we
see when we watch the tape, he's
one-on-one.
No Antonio, Brown means more
dependence on Gronk. So I think
that Tom is Tom is purposely
coming out trying to get ra
Gronk to ball trying to And have
that, that chemistry, that
continuity with them,
but I think it's great, man. I'm
so proud of Rob Gronkowski
the sacrifices that he's making
for his body. So he can stay
out there. He can play. And you
better believe he's on that TV
12, because he looks, he looks
good.
Now, I'm about to get on that t.
B12 here in a second. Let's
get you to your fifth take away
and I want to get some sound
involved here too. So this is
the Ravens, the Steelers,
right? This whole rivalry
every time these two meet
forget about the record is going
to be a great game when
they're on the field here was
coach Tom window right after
the game talking about Coach
horrible and is use of
analytics. This is fun. Listen
to this.
No,
it did not. You know, they
aggressively play analytics
and And so, you know, from that
standpoint, they're
predictable.
You know what? Let me just say
this. I don't really think it's
analytics. I just think that
Coach Harbaugh has a feel for
his team and when he came out
and said, look, we don't have
any cornerbacks.
I'm agree with them. You should
go forward, you got, you got
Mark Andrews. You got a little
more, you know, you've been out
in this situation before like I
don't blame them. So
I don't think it's necessarily
analytics. I just think that he
had a feel for his team. I mean
if they're dropping like flies
and you lost your Best Corner
mall in Hunt for you lost
a bunch of other guys. When the
season
like go for it, I'm not mad at
Harbaugh for going for. We were
there earlier in the year when
they played against Kansas City
and he won the game being
aggressive,
you know, and this is
this is all, am are right here.
Lamar has to. He has to make
that play. He has to make that
play.
We've solved for two straight
weeks, Lamar missing. Easy
passes thrown into the defense.
He's got to get back confident.
He's got to step into that throw
and anything that Mark
Andrews has
hit his hands. He's caught the
last two or three years.
So, Lamar's gonna have to step
up, be able to make these type
of plays. If they want to
continue to move forward.
This is an easy play, right?
Yeah. It's a belief thing.
Right. I'm with you probably
should have do for that.
Definitely should have had two
hands out there on a 4th down.
I mean, you gotta put, you gotta
You Gotta Go full
extension. After one like that.
I would think and it was I'm
not going to question Market
from, I'm not going to court
question. Mark Andrews. I'm not
going to question mark Andrews
with that.
He's expecting the ball to be on
a money. And when you throw
the ball away up here, you can't
reach for it because he's
running toward the sideline. So
I don't put that on Mark
Andrews. I put that on Lamar and
we like I told you the week
before
we watched him, throw. How many
interceptions was it for?
I use three and one quarter
three in the second quarter
alone,
right? Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah, so, it's a belief
thing, right? And at some
point, the belief might run out,
but I, the thing
I remember from the
prior Sunday night, which I
think was the Kansas City game
was the conversation that Lamar
how with tar ball, where he
basically just goes, the more do
you want to go for? I mean,
do you remember that? And Lamar
said, hell, yeah, I want to go
for it. And they,
they went right back out there
went for it and got it. So for
me, it's a belief thing. But if
you stop getting them, if
you're not able to hit that
pass.
The belief might start to go out
a little bit and I also
think Tom would just wanted to
get a little troll on the back
end because there's no doubt
that the Ravens have been
a team that on fourth down,
especially, fourth and short,
they feel like they're built for
it and consistently,
they're going after it. And for
the
most part, it's been great
results for him. It just didn't
work out this time.
Yeah, and I look at defensively
they lost Marlon Humphrey their
best defensive back and it
wasn't like he was having
an All-Pro year or even a pro
bono year. But he's a guy that
everybody looks to he's getting
paid a heck of a lot of money
and that's a huge huge loss
for those guys.
Let's see this AFC playoff
picture right now. It's a big
loss for the Baltimore Ravens.
You just hit on. So, here's how
the playoffs currently sit.
9 and 4 are the New England
Patriots. They already have
that one seed in the AFC. My dad
didn't take long. So you
still got the Titans hanging out
there at the to, but that's
a team. That's a very beat up.
Baltimore has played
some sloppy sloppy football,
but still found ways to win
those games late. What's going
through your mind? Looking at
this AFC playoff picture right
now?
I get excited when I see the
Patriots, okay,
the Chiefs and the coats. Those
are the teams. Like
there's a lot going on with the
two or three seeds with
the Titans and the Ravens. But
when I look at the coach, the
way
they're running the ball, the
way Carson Winters playing with
such confidence. They got a good
defense. The Colts are
a team that I wouldn't want to
play. I wouldn't want to really
sneak up on a coach because
they're big.
They're physical their offensive
line. We talked about
left guard, Quentin, Nelson
getting healthier.
Seems like He's starting to play
a little better.
A if it fits any of these teams,
I don't want to play
the Colts in that run game.
Yeah, I'm with you on that steel
or still lingering
the other team that could get
interesting and they would have
to get healthy and I almost
don't know how healthy that
Baker Mayfield can get. Given
just this slew of injuries that
he's battling through, but their
defense, to me looks
really talented. If Baker in
this offense,
it's always going to be a run
dominant offense. But if Baker
can just get a little bit
healthier and just do enough in
that passing game. I mean, how
good was Miles Garrett against
the Ravens on that Sunday night
game. That is a very talented
defensive Baker can just
give them something at the
quarterback spot.